Gates suspects the vending machine was
made by Dominion well thousands have
been left without power due to a
hurricane in Puerto Rico a Canadian oil
tanker is on its way from Florida with
life-saving supplies and what will
surely end this crisis
[Music]
habitat is restricted to American
vessels thanks to the Jones act waste
the tanker's right there correct it has
to dock in a foreign Port before it can
dock here obviously coming up what the
U.S is doing to reduce Global carbon
emissions
[Music]
foreign
but I'm right off the coast
forcing him to go back to Canada just to
come right now we're desperate I'm gonna
waste so much
[Music]